well yes earth day is this friday april
22nd and the nation's largest student
farmers market is returning to downtown
summerlin under the pavilion and here to
tell us more about it is the chief
growth officer of green our planet
brittany dupree welcome brittany it's so
good to see you this is such a cool
event well first of all let's talk about
green our planet what do you guys do
yeah so we are a non-profit 501c3
founded here in las vegas in 2013 we
connect students and children to
the universe and uh kind of in encourage
a really amazing appreciation for our
planet and we do that through indoor and
outdoor school gardens so we have 196
outdoor school gardens here in las vegas
and we're also in 16 states as well as
alaska with our indoor school gardens in
hydroponics units which are those
machines where you can grow all your
stuff which i just got one and all of a
sudden i have like lettuce in this thing
i'm like wow that's amazing and so that
is what we do so what kind of produce
are these kids yeah they're growing
everything so they are growing broccoli
they're growing strawberries uh they
have beets i think i just saw a picture
of a beet from one of the gardens that
was huge and one of the competitions at
the farmers market is heaviest
vegetables so they're all working really
hard to grow the heaviest vegetable
we have rosemary and herbs and lettuce
and all kinds of stuff so this friday
you can go down to the summerlin
downtown summerlin and you can purchase
you can purchase yes and so it's really
exciting we've actually been doing this
for nine years but this is our first
time back in two years because of the
pandemic and actually for almost all of
these kids it's the first field trip
that they've done in two and a half
years because they've been in the
classroom or at home right
and so they will come we have 50 schools
coming so 500 students and they will
bring all of their produce and they have
been working all year most of them are
fifth graders and they've gone through a
financial literacy program where they
learn how to turn the farmers market and
their garden into a business so they're
pricing they're doing market research
and they're learning how to uh negotiate
which i've heard they are really good at
really yes and they bring it all and
then it's in the same space at downtown
summerlin as the regular farmers market
and they'll sell from 9 30 a.m to 1 p.m
how do these kids feel when they go out
there and get to see i've heard them say
that it's the best day ever
i think one of the things so our theme
for this year is a burst of joy because
we understand right that our teachers
and our kids have been through a lot and
so we are there to make sure that they
are just joyful and that they feel
empowered and we're empowering them
through learning how to run their own
business yeah when does this all start
so it starts at 9 30 okay friday earth
day the 22nd the market opens at 9 30
and it closes at 1 o'clock okay so you
want to get there early because i have a
feeling yes they they sell out so come
early and if you can bring cash however
we will have credit cards but cash is
easier yeah i'm sure it with the
negotiating system cash is king yeah
i definitely want there
such a great organization too and for
more information do you guys have a
website too yes it's uh
greener
greenerplanet.org i believe
sorry about that thank you
definitely want to check it out kevin
will send it over to you thanks